der sprung ist das also einen sprung
unfassbar davos als kind sondern
willkommen zu einer neuen folge gay
adventure mit logo und tom von enya
jockey und wir nehmen uns heute zwei
maps vor und zwar einmal die
wunderschöne fernöstliche reise nach iso
profils und hier drüben die grünen
hätten halt die schnauze so lasst uns
starten kurs nummer fünf ist die green
person difficulty vier von sechs ich
habe übrigens dass ich noch kurz
erklären aber das logo nach nach der
letzten folge hat logo sie einfach
gedacht ja ich bin logo juckt mich nicht
und er wirft einfach so hin und sagt so
es gekommen hier weil ich so jahr scheiß
drauf wenn dann aber doch hin und er ist
so langsam den aufzuheben und deswegen
habe ich jetzt drei diaz du wolltest du
wieder ein bisschen gelaufen bisschen
aufregung
okay okay ist es so green lösung ihrer
geschichte
you can find free hätten diamonds in der
kurs 1 4 mrd m3 versteckte vier am ende
alles klar jungs die alles klar okay da
mache ich genau wie immer playlist
findet auf allen stellen sind auch alle
in der beschreibung verlinkt falls ich
noch nicht kennt habt ihr nicht gesagt
ich bin etwas komisch fertig und gabriel
und mich zu früh gestartet aber das
machen alle die auf den sommer das oder
fabrik aber ihr wisst gar nicht dass ich
in der community immer nur jump n runs
spiele
ach quatsch bist du bist doch in der
community der ja wahrscheinlich
selbst nicht gespaßt sie auch noch alle
genau wir müssen uns gegen logo
verbünden hinterherkommen gegen logo
verbinden kommen jetzt wer als nächstes
haut trägt drei sekunden er kriegt 15
sekunden time out ist einfach frieden
jetzt ist einfach den frieden
man darf hauen aber dann gibt's 50
timeout wie das geht ist auch schon die
das am besten ok aber in ein nicht diese
art von time out nicht die sat 1 1 o
mein gott ich hab's geschafft
entweder einen riegel regeln halten oder
erstmal die das internet was mein leben
zum kopf des bak using lasten wie im
time outen
da kommt da nicht lang macht den check
von auf augenhöhe benutzen sie noch
nicht einmal auf abgemachte musste für
dich selbst aufmachen wenn du jetzt
scheitert dann muss er benutze nicht wie
benutzen denen noch nie bedürfen
benutzen
es wäre schön malicks bestimmen
ach quatsch tippten auf gemacht oder das
logo wieder logo colo colo colo colo
gerd timeout ach komm nicht so stürmisch
mit den jungen pferden rasten passiert
betrifft das ist meine hat einfach so
geile timeout ddos nein du muss runter
muss lotter und bleibt stehen weg ja
weil ich die strafe vollziehen musste
längst ich mache das gerne denke ich
mache das gerne oder denkst du es gerne
ich finde die oberfläche leiten
das geld wie sie auch kommen nicht das
alter logos wie jetzt gerade die
britische liga auf ist dass man das
machen und wir beginnst du immer alles
etf wtf stimmte da irgendwie irgendwo
irgendwann so was ist es stimmt ja
bestimmt jemand viel macht man keine mit
in der end kissen für die ascot
ja ja ja ich habe auch ein loch in das
ich für mich kein login des don ein loch
in sein board du mich am arsch
ich bin jetzt richtig weit hinten
tatsächlich tatsächlich aber ich bin ich
bin durch und durch
ich habe abgebrochen aber dadurch nicht
okay wir zweiter wurde zweiter
sprich abgebrochen war es war hab ich
kein bock mit aufgehört hat das alles ja
aber ich kann die ganze folge gelb aber
ich eigentlich auch oder ich bin ja ich
bin hier raus neben hier raus doch hier
raus gerade warum ich wohl die letzte
tor sein könnt ihr euch für druck kamen
zu tun und der wirkliche gibt es noch
eine 3 blog sagt oder reise vier die uns
also ich hab eingeholt leider muss hier
noch zwei kisten geben die kasse das
denn ja wir haben 7 das gibt's ja genau
sie sei sie gefunden
noch einen habe ich gefunden
ein gibt es noch in dieser welt
eingenommen wie viel die jetzt hast du
dann hab ich habe auch viel jetzt
gleichstand ist es deutschland
abkürzen kann ich eigentlich ziemlich
neues von dem da unsere block damit
nicht abkürzen kann nicht gerade
gefeiert
schon wieder
wo waren diese in der nächsten folge
muss ich am dom vorbei ziehen leute wir
müssen ihn müssen in rasieren amorim mit
benzin gegen den strich
die soko feels so doof jetzt ja die
bäume sind schon so dann lasst mich ich
wollte ich geb dir wieder da müssen wir
hier ist hast du das buch das ist echt
nicht bauten ist sieht schick aus
789 die drei versteckten und am ende
fünf diaz und wenn logo das heute
schafft dann klatsche ich den so weg
dann wollen die hoffnung auf den erste
festzustellen
321 wie man einfach nicht sieht
auch wirklich gar nichts los geh weg ali
geh weg geh weg nicht stimmig combo
geschmeckt wo ständig im weg rum
ob ihr den weg um weiter
logo getan die dinge nicht ab
ich musste gerade alle auf die
checkpoints ok sätze waren schon alle
auf noch kommt ich nutze ich nutzen
du bist jetzt ruhig piano ich bin auch
ein bisschen als km/h hat dann eben das
ist aber wirklich voll die hübsche map
ist novoselov ist wird dies weiter
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein
und jetzt ein bisschen kürzer springen
so perfekt zum herunter oder youtube
herunter ich war zu kurz davor in meiner
folge den dicken jackpot zu retten
ja das nein ich war wieder runter aber
ist es schwierig ich finde das gar nicht
so schwierig der letzte sprung ist ein
bisschen katjes es geschafft und logos
oder vor mir oder wie acht kommen pinsel
dich immer weg herr logo ist doch gar
nicht hier das kann ich hier den
kompletten
den kompletten vor hinweg gemacht danke
dass ich geil
nein
beim allerletzten sprung zu der letzten
leiter vom checker mutter geworden
also wir beide an mir vorbei war
ich bin drin gewesen hat mich geküsst
und das warum vielleicht natürlich
gehörig durch durch irgendwie aufnahme
recht bei schlägen dass man meinen
aufnahmen hat schlagen darf das war geil
alter jetzt plötzlich will man das an
der nächsten ecke hier zu leben weil er
bei der nächsten dann nicht mehr bei der
nächsten nicht mehr weil dann was dann
stellt sich heraus dass -unfall
wichtigsten alle im weg himmel nein ich
habe noch so schlank bleibe hier ich
schlag dich kurz funktioniert das ganze
ist zu wissen kannst du auch mal
verpassen
ich stelle mir immer drüber
es tut mir echt leid leute
nein ich fahr runter aber gut ich war
ich war aber noch nicht ganz am
checkpoint musste nochmal voll zurück
ich außerdem oft gemacht hast dann muss
man denn hier lang heute frage ich bin
ja auch schon gar nicht mehr durch warum
ich hier immer runter ich gehe ich
weigere mich da noch mal rein zu gehen
das ist kacke
das hätte ich mir für kraft und bisschen
arg konzentriertes gerade recht ich noch
mein gott warum müssen das denn auch
japanische leider sprünge seien
warum kann man nicht es reicht mir jetzt
dadurch zum checkpoint gehen bitte danke
aber wenn ich das schaffst dann bekommst
du welche diamanten
da machen wir da machen wir hälfte
hälfte aber ich habe so eine blockade
das kann sich kein land anschauen
what the [ __ ] sehr schwer der sprung der
sehr schwer
der nachfolgende rom ein gott der
nachfrage sagte der nachfolgende er da
musste halter lasse hat mich mit dingen
um die ecke louis du musst ja nicht nur
um die ecke sondern muss danach noch mal
eins hoch das ist total kompliziert
ok alltag er ist es aber es ist machbar
ja er ist nicht so schwer fallen leider
habe ich hier bei lisa aktiv aki dieses
haus hat mich so auseinander genommene
ist das schwer
ich mache jetzt aber ziemlich hektisch
ist nicht so hektisch ich warte ich
werde die ganze vorfall hektisch ich
hatte am anfang die führung alter ist
man dahin springen muss nein nicht mehr
ich auch nein ich war fast
nein das gibt es nicht
gibson und immer wieder geschafft habe
ich den auch du auch die harten fakten
aber nicht ich hab nicht gesprengt wird
warum ich wollte immer runter da muss
man so hier um die ecke springen
gewinnen was mit meinen haaren
ich will auch baku gewinnen ich habe
bisher nur mit zeit die erst mal meinen
papa gemacht und mit einem nicht ihr
geschenk dass wir kein geschenk du warst
du zu dem dann wieder aufzusammeln
doch gar nicht du hast du bist wieder
hingelaufen aufsammeln das ganze kannst
jetzt nicht vertuschen er ja 12.45 bis
sie wird er nicht und der sprung ist das
also einen sprung unfassbar leide ich
gerne mitmachen völlig überrissen
umfliegen
machen wir es gibt nach dingen die die
kann ich ja schon anfangen zu suchen
während ihr das noch macht müssen wir
fertig machen bevor die ansuchen dürfen
prinzip prinzipiell nicht habe ich habe
auch nicht eigentlich nicht so sind
jetzt erstmal eine riesige map die
können hier überall versteckt sein
du hast jetzt um 10 sowohl alter krass
zehn stück da ja wohl ja wir wollen ja
wohl noch eingefunden
ich habe nur jemand nachgemacht von
9live er wolle ja wohl ja wie ich also
ich glaube die werden
ich habe glaube ich ein gesehen jedoch
nicht falscher alarm
ich habe eingesehen aber das wird es
nicht machen weil er es gewagt ist
nämlich nicht und was werden
geschlagen ich lösten immer sagen okay
12 15
lang war es wohl das kommt hast du das
und welche gesehen ich war das umsonst
hier weißt einfach so weil ich bock
drauf an erhält hat doch an lösungen es
war ja so schön da hat doch erst rein
alles treibt
unfassbar holt er sich die nächte sind
gut versteckt
wie kannst du nur so viele diamond
sketchen gut versteckt hat darunter
geschlagen gewesen
aber ich darf irgendwie am boden gibt es
keine am boden feiern die nicht so ja am
bodensee ist nicht so die paar leute
muss kein problem machen es einfach nur
hoch laufen
das kann doch mal gemacht weil ich
dachte oh what the [ __ ] wie doch bin ich
denn doch bin ich denn jedes geschäft
plan einfach noch mal gemacht ob graz
aber dass dummheit von mir gerade ach so
ja da ist noch eine kiste gut
scheiß er komm gehen wir halt jetzt
wollte ich geil nur darum schon auf name
schluss oder als ich meinen von dem
mehrwert 20 minuten alle menschen auf ja
jetzt schluss im amarok los mal die
sache kommt mal die sache alles klar
jump'n'run ist nochmal games nicht wir
werden aber sehen wir jetzt in den
nächsten folgen bei den anderen
abschneidet vielleicht kann ich noch ein
bisschen reißen und dom ist zumindest
noch einmal würde ich sagen lassen doch
noch unglaublich gefallen hat die
anderen sind die beschreibung passt gut
und